hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu vlogmas
Tag 20 oh mein Gott eine zwei steht
vorne das ist alleine schon eine
Premiere für sich also wenn ich das
jetzt auch nicht durchziehen kann bis
zum 24 ich habe es geschafft bis 20 und
ich fühle mich tatsächlich genauso
kaputt wie ich gerade aussehe in den
letzten 20 Minuten ist meine Haut
irgendwie total rot geworden das ist
manchmal so das ist ganz komisch
wirklich wenn meine Knöchel kalt werden
dann kriege ich ein rotes Gesicht ja
macht mit der Information was ihr wollt
so wir färben heute meine Haare also ihr
helft mir dabei ne ihr müsst gleich die
Farbe halten und den Pinsel und was weiß
ich nicht alles und ich dachte damit ich
Timo ein bisschen wieder mit dem Schnitt
und mit dem ganzen workload ein bisschen
entlasten kann machen wir wieder so ein
bisschen so ein oneaker also diese Folge
wird jetzt ein bisschen entspannter
falls ihr irgendwas zu tun habt sowas
wie Wäsche aufhängen den Boden wischen
dann könnt ihr das jetzt perfekt machen
packt euch Kopfhörer rein oder guckt das
auf dem Fernseher und dann ist das für
euch ein kleines haartutorial ich habe
das schon öfter
gemacht falls ihr das schon mal gesehen
habt das ist irgendwie so ein Standard
Ding dass ich mich beim Haarefärben
Filme wir sehen genug perfekte
influencer also da kann ich doch jetzt
rotwangig mal eine Abwechslung sein so
ich benutze sonst immer SOS dunkelbraun
heute probiere ich mal SOS schwarz keine
Ahnung ob mir das stehen wird aber ich
hatte mal Bock ein bisschen auf
Veränderung und wenn ich gerade in so
einem Laden bin wir waren heute shoppen
und wenn ich dort bin dann sehen meine
Haare immer so ganz komisch fleckig aus
also ich habe B hier dunkel und ab da
dann hell und ja so im Alltag stört's
mich nicht aber wenn ich mich dann bei
richtig hellem Licht sehe nee das muss
ich nicht mehr haben und ich hatte eine
Zeit lang schwarze Haare ich habe dann
immer so ein leichten schnewitchen Weib
und das probieren wir heute mal aus und
damit wir auch so ein richtiges Thema
haben über das wir sprechen können bzw
ich ich sage immer wir aber du worüber
ich sprechen kann sind zehn Dinge die
ich in
bereue mir ist das alles auch manchmal
zu positiv hier auf dem Kanal wisst ihr
ihr schreibt mir so nette Kommentare ich
habe das Gefühl vlogmis ist ein voller
Erfolg bei euch gewesen jetzt nicht von
Zahlen und wie viel Geld man damit
verdient da ist Adventskalender wirklich
Adventskalender Auspacken 100 mal
lukrativer aber
wenn man daran so also wenn wenn man an
die Kommentare und wenn ich die sehe
dann denke ich nee das war doch das
macht doch Spaß hier die Leute sind da
und ja ich find total toll wie ihr mich
supportet und wie ihr mich anfeuert dass
das dieses Jahr endlich mal was wird mit
dem
blogm ehrlich gesagt habe ich aber auch
irgendwie gedacht na ja irgendwie darf
es ja auch nicht werden ne irgendwie
müssen wir das jetzt hier vorzeitig
abbrechen damit das auch noch real
bleibt und jetzt geht es auch schon ran
an den Speck Dinge die ich
2023 bereut habe Nummer
ein ja Nummer ein ist jetzt nicht etwas
was ich wirklich bereuen kann weil ich
nicht so viel Schuld habe
aber bzw doch ich bereue es so viel fomo
Gefühl zu haben ich bin jemand von dem
ich dachte dass ich gar nicht so unter
fomo leide also falls ihr nicht wisst
was das heißt fear of
also die Angst davor etwas zu verpassen
und ich dachte ich bin jetzt nicht so
eine Person ich musste aber mit dem
deichbrandfestival merken
doch ich kann richtig fomo haben dieses
Jahr hatte ich halt nicht so Schuld
daran also ich habe es nicht entschieden
nicht aufs Deichbrand zu gehen
sondern ich hatte es ganz noral geplant
dahin und alles war schon organisiert
kriegen ja immer diese e love Content wo
wir
m geschützt in einem geschützten Rahmen
schlafen können ohne dass wir z.B jetzt
mit jedem zeltnachbar Fotos machen
müssen oder
ja können das ist immer so witzig wenn
die Leute halt fragen oder sagen ja
wieso kriegen diese influencer diesen
extra Bereich also dass da so ein paar
also dass da z.B Zelte schon vorher
stehen und so das ist halt mega nett
einfach und das ganz ehrlich jeder würde
das mit Handkuss annehmen warum aber so
ein extra Bereich halt gut ist ist dass
wir halt auch dort sein können wir
übernehmen Marketing für das Deichbrand
da freuen die sich weil dann sparen die
sich halt die Poster die sie dann
irgendwo an Wänden kleben sondern dann
machen sie das durch uns und genau wir
können da halt in geschützten Rahmen
sein so ich fange mal mit meinem Ansatz
an
ne na ja und dann war ich jetzt dieses
Jahr auch wieder eingeladen und hatte
schon alles geplant
mit freunden dahin zufahren
pipao und dann ist mir einfach fünf Tage
vorher oder sechs Tage vorher der
blinddam der hat sich entzündet und ich
lag im Krankenhaus wurde operiert und
irgendwie war ich relativ schnell wieder
fit und wusste die ganze Zeit nicht
fahre ich fahre ich nicht
ich wusste halt schon dass ich halt
keinen Alkohol trinken werde und halt
total aufpassen muss aber ich hatte halt
so frische Wunden dass das auf keinen
Fall klar gegangen wäre und das wäre
viel zu gefährlich gewesen wenn da einer
auf im Konzert so einmal reingeditcht
wäre dann hätte ich mir da irgendwas
aufgerissen ja und deswegen
m habe ich dann meine Freunde
ähm die Plätze
übergeben also die sind dann alle ohne
mich gefahren das war total nett dass
das Deichbrand halt die dann trotzdem
noch genommen hat also ich meine wir
hatten das Zelt und die hätten jetzt
auch nicht so schnell Ersatz finden
können aber trotzdem es war mega nett
also ich ich liebe auch immer noch die
Stories von meiner Schulfreundin also
ist wirklich eine Freundin von damals
nicht Annie meine Managerin die ist das
ja schon gewohnt diese fancy Geschichten
mit ihr war ich ja auch z.B in Las Vegas
also ich glaube für sie ist das
mittlerweile auch irgendwo normal aber
meine Schulfreundin aus alten Zeiten
alten Tagen die für die war das völlig
neu und ach ich habe ich habe so geliebt
ihre Reaktion die ganze Zeit zu bekommen
und dann ja habe ich immer so sprachn
oder Fotos bekommen und dann waren
Diemer total happy war oh mein Gott
Vanessa das ist so krass hier und so das
war schon cool aber was ich halt bereue
ist dass ich halt so fomo ganze Zeit
gefühlt habe und das nicht einfach
akzeptieren konnte und ich weiß nicht
wie man das lernt oder wie man da an
sich arbeiten kann aber ich wäre gerne
mehr akzeptierend gewesen über die
Situation und nicht so ja also ich habe
mich echt scheiße teilweise gefühlt weil
ich ganze Halit irgendwie dann doch
geguckt habe ah was machen die oh jetzt
haben die das und oh jetzt ist das so
und und ich hätte mir das Leben halt
einfach viel leichter gemacht hätte ich
einfach von Sekunde 1 an akzeptiert ich
habe auch die ganze Zeit versucht
irgendwie noch hin und her zu druen und
zu sagen vielleicht komme ich ja doch
mit und bis zum letzten Tag habe ich mir
so schwer gemacht und das würde ich
gerne nicht mehr machen in Zukunft wenn
das Schicksal etwas entscheidet möchte
ich das Schicksal annehmen
egal
wie schwierig es ist oder wie nervig
also glaub mir ich habe in meinem Leben
schon schwierige Schicksals Schläge
gehabt als
das aber irgendwie wenn es dann um das
Thema fomo ging und halt dieses alle
haben Spaß und ich nicht da war ich dann
doch schon
richtig habe ich m einach blöd gefühlt
ich habe mich gze do irgendwie über mich
selbst geärgert und für 2024 drücke ich
meine Daumen so fest dass das nicht noch
mal passiert
denn ich fah nächstes Jahr wieder aufs
Deichbrand und wisst ihr wer da sein
wird Nina Schuba und ich freue mich da
extrem drauf sie haben auch zurzeit
einen Adventskalender und in ihrem
Adventskalender geben Sie jeden Tag
Preis welcher Künstler welche Künstlerin
auftreten wird nächstes Jahr also checkt
auf jeden Fall mal diesen
adventskkalender aus auf der
deichbrandseite und
übrigens Leute ich habe kein rabattk
aber ich kann zwei Tickets verlosen und
ich möchte die richtig schnell verlosen
und deswegen habt ihr ab jetzt 24
Stunden Zeit auf Instagram da gibt's
einen neuen Post von mir zwei
deichbrandkarten zu gewinnen ich habe
sie auch da die
liegen die liegen nur im Wohnzimmer ich
zeig sie später vielleicht noch mal
genau das ist keine bezahlte Werbung
oder so aber das Deichbrand ist einfach
mein absolutes lieblingsfestival
vielleicht weil ich auch aus dem Norden
komme und die letzten Jahre war das
schon so cool dass ja ich die gerne
supporte und ja ich werde halt
eingeladen das ist dann das ist auf
jeden Fall ein Pluspunkt für mich ich
bin ja
auch froh wenn ich dann was zurückgeben
kann gell also geht nach dem Video rüber
auf Instagram oder geht jetzt kurz aber
kommt bitte wieder wenn ihr Youtube
Premium habt dann könnt ihr Youtube
schließen meine Stimme weiterhören und
dann auf eine andere App gehen also
falls ihr noch nicht Youtube Premium
habt Leute gönnt euch die haben wurden
aber jetzt teurer das ist ein bisschen
nervig aber ich könnte nie wieder zurück
also wenn ich mit ein anderen Account
auf Youtube bin dann sehe ich immer erst
wie anstrengend Werbung ist ich kenne
das halt gar nicht mehr weil ich glaube
ich seit zwei Jahren Youtube Premium hab
und da ich selber so viel Youtube gucke
und mir irgendwann gesagt scheiße das
muss ich schnell wegmachen reden und
arbeiten das ist keine gute Idee da ich
auch Spotify habe und dafür auch ein
Zehner im Monat gebe und halt auch Musik
und Podcast so ein bisschen höre dachte
ich so ey ich bin so viel auf Youtube
ich gucke jeden Tag und das einzige was
mich von Youtube Premium abgehalten war
hat war einfach dass ich das von früher
nicht gewohnt war für Youtube zu
bezahlen aber ich möchte keinen Tag
wieder zurück timo hat irgendwann sein
Youtube Premium
gekündigt weil er sich halt auch dachte
gut dann spart er sich das ein der hat
sich das nach zwei Monaten wieder geholt
weil man einfach die Werbung das hält
doch keiner aus das ist doch also ich
freue mich natürlich ne durch die
Werbung wird mein ben finanziert und so
kann ich meine Videos machen aber
trotzdem Youtube Premium wä halt besser
und wenn man mit YouTube Premium we
Videos schaut dann kriege ich auch was
davon also das ist nicht nicht schlecht
aber ich kann es natürlich auch
verstehen wenn man sich nicht leisten
kann also gerade zur Zeit das ist also
das da verlange ich nie von niemanden
dass er noch mal extra 12 € für Youtube
Premium ausgibt ich hätte ein Vorschlag
GEZ günstiger machen und jedem YouTube
Premium gönnen das wäre doch toll ich
glaube da würde sich die meiste junge
Zielgruppe drüber freuen wenn Sie Ihr
GEZ in Youtube Premium umtauschen
dürften Sachen die ich bereue als Nummer
2 was ich in 2023 bereut habe ich habe
ja Skifahren gelernt habt ihr alle
gesehen und Monte hatte dieses
skifahrevent wisst ihr in welcher Halle
ich Skifahren gelernt habe ich hatte ja
Video gepostet da habe ich mit Samira
zusammen meine erste skistunde gehabt
das war in der Skihalle
bisbing wo ist montes Event in der
Skihalle bisbing und ich bereue es so
sehr nicht irgendwie über dreie Ecken
mich auf dieses Event
mitzusneaken also halt irgendwie an
Monte ranzukommen und ihn zu fragen ob
ich da auch hinkommen
darf und also bestimmt war das auch ein
tolles Event und so aber ich hätte so
Lust gehabt als Full Circle Moment
einfach auf diesem Event Ski zu fahren
weil ich dann noch mal gucken könnte wie
kann ich jetzt Skifahren und wie
wie viel besser bin ich geworden als zum
letzten Mal es muss sich ja extrem
verbessert haben weil ich in der Schweiz
ja auch noch so viel gefahren bin und
irgendwann dort halt richtig gut fahren
konnte also meiner Meinung nach und ja
ich
glaube
das hätte halt richtig cool werden
können und ich wäre im Hintergrund
einfach die ganze Zeit Ski gefahren
während da alle Livestream irgendwelche
Sachen
reden ja da habe ich mich geärgert und
dann hat die auch halt voll fomo dann
habe ich immer wieder auf dieses Event
geschalten und dachte immer so
mann ich will da
Skifahren ist ja auch total cool weil
die ja diese Skihalle für sich hatten
was lerne ich daraus für
2024 nicht viel mich mehr auf influencer
Events sneaken wenn ich nicht eingeladen
bin ich bin ja schon bei viel eingeladen
aber in dieser ganzen Streamer
Youtube Streamer Monte sevenw wild
Community die da bin ich gar nicht drin
ich geh halt noch zu den oldscho
Youtubern sag ich mal obwohl da waren
auch viele oldscho Youtuber ich weiß
nicht ich bin da ich bin da überhaupt
nicht in der connecke drin ich muss mal
wieder ein bisschen networken und
socializen es kann do nicht sein dass
ich seit 5 Jahren keine neuen Leute
kennengelernt habe obwohl s habe ich
kennengelernt und bei der Spoiler ich
mal bin ich jetzt ja übermorgen bin ich
bei S erstmal
überlegen und wir drehen aber bei für
ihren Kanal Sachen die aber erst viel
später kommen ey das Schwarz ist blau
oh
nein meine ganze Stirn wird voll sein
oh eine Geschichte ich sag keine Details
aber ich hatte dieses Jahr eine
Geschichte da war mein Stolz so im Weg
dass ich eine so krasse Gelegenheit
einfach weggeworfen habe weil mein Stolz
gekränkt war ich sag nicht ich gebe gar
keine Hinweise oder sonst was ich möchte
auch nicht dass da rum geraten wird das
einzige was ich halt sagen kann ist ich
habe mich so dumm
Verhalten ja und habe dadurch einfach
total die Chance verpasst auf etwas
richtig cooles einfach nur weil mein
Stolz im Weg war und in dem Moment
dachte ich wirklich ich bin im Recht und
das ist schon gerechtfertig wie ich mich
fühle und wirklich eine Woche später
habe ich es so bereut weil dann dieses
stolzgefühl weg war und alles was
geblieben war ist
dieses diese ewige
Lehre einfach einfach das Gefühl von
meine Fresse bist du dumm und das Bo das
mag ich ja gar nicht ne andere
enttäuschen ist okay für mich mich
selber
enttäuschen geht gar nicht wenn ich
andere ent täusche denke ich immer so ja
komm hab mal bitte nicht zu zu hohe
Erwartungen wenn ich mich selber
enttäusche ja ich habe zu hohe Erwartung
an mich selbst wenn ich mich dann selbst
enttäusche dann ja und das möchte ich in
2024 besser machen da möchte ich einfach
mein Stolz auch mal runterschlucken und
auch mal Sachen machen oder sagen die
ich dann vielleicht wo ich dann
vielleicht lieber gemeckert hätte oder
halt
trotzig gewesen wäre
trotzigkeit nicht in
24 tomatengesicht absolut ja boah guck
mal das ist richtig als ob ich so ein
Sekt getrunken hätte und das habe ich so
selten natürlich aber dann wenn ich
drehe ohne Make-up abends um 10 aber das
ist die beste Zeit um seine Haare zu
färben 10 Uhr wenn man es geplant früher
macht dann hat man sein Leben zu sehr
unter Kontrolle Nummer 4 was ich dieses
Jahr
bereue dass ich noch nicht mit meinem
Podcast angefangen habe ich weiß nicht
ob ich das jemals erzählt habe aber vor
5 Jahren vor vier oder 5 Jahren habe ich
schon mal einen Podcast aufgenommen und
ich hatte schon so vier Folgen mit
jemand anderen zusammen und aus
irgendeinem Grund habe ich es danach
einfach nicht mehr gefühlt ich kann aber
im besten will nicht sagen warum ich es
nicht also wirklich gar kein Plan warum
ich das nicht gefühlt habe ich habe es
einfach irgendwie dann nicht mehr
gefühlt und kam mir dann irgendwie blöd
vor und dachte irgendwie nee dieser
Podcast das ist es nicht so habe danach
irgendwie nicht mehr wirklich dieses
Thema aufgerollt doch so seit zwei
Jahren denke ich die ganze Zeit komm ey
probier es doch einmal das das mein
größtes Hobby wenn mich fragen würde das
ist sich unterhalten ich liebe es zu
reden also auch vor mit anderen sich zu
unterhalten und es gibt so Leute da ich
habe das Gefühl kennt ihr das wenn
Menschen in irgendwas in euch rausggern
ich habe so in meinem Leben immer wieder
Leute kennengelernt z.B Anika ist so
eine Person wenn ich mit Anika also an
dieicion mich unterhalte dann fühle ich
mich immer so richtig angespornt
irgendwie funny Sprüche zu sagen und
irgendwas rauszuhauen und bin so richtig
mein kreativen Nervenzellen werden so
richtig angehal und
ich ja baller so einpruch nach dem
anderen raus nicht dass die alle super
lustig sind aber ich merke auf jeden
Fall da habe ich immer so richtig
Motivation lustige Sachen zu sagen und
solche Menschen habe ich üers Leben
immer wieder kennengelernt und mit so
einer Person hätte ich dann halt auch
gerne Podcast wo ich mich so
gechallenged fühle lustig sein zu wollen
also nicht dass ein Podcast immer lustig
sein muss aber wenn ich ein Podcast
mache dann will ich schon gemischtes
Hack Konkurrenz machen
und fest und flauschig aber gemischte
Sack finde ich gar nicht mehr so gut ich
weiß auch nicht warum ich finde
gemischtes Hack wird gerade wieder ein
bisschen besser ich gebe immer noch
nicht auf M aber irgendwie stimmt die
Dynamik zwischen Tommy und Felix gar
nicht mehr das war eine Zeit lang
unerträglich fand ich wie Felix da
irgendwie ihn als so nicht lustig
dargestellt hat und wie Tommy dann aber
auch irgendwie der war dann der wirkte
eine Zeit lang traurig und beleidigt so
im Unterton als ob der auch schon
aufgegeben hätte sich gegen Felix da
aufzu anzulehnen mir fällt das Wort
nicht ein ihr wisst was ich meine ich
glaube die hatten so ein Krisengespräch
ich vermute die hatten so ein
Krisengespräch und Tommy hat so gesagt
ey wenn du nicht aufhörst immer dich
über mich lustig zu machen und sichich
mich so schlecht zu machen und mir so
ein schlechtes Gefühl zu geben Bruder
dann kann ich den Podcast nicht mehr
weitermachen schwö dann hat Felix gesagt
so e Bruder ich glaube ich habe mich ein
bisschen verrannt aber ich gebe mir Mühe
ja hat er gesagt danke Bruder ja so ist
das Gespräch ungefähr abgelaufen falls
euch wundert ey dass diese
Farbe das aus dieser Farbe Blau also auf
meinem Kopf blau und dann schwarz wird
das ist Magie Leute wartet nicht auf
euren
hoogwartsbef die Magie passiert vor
euren Augen ihr seht's nur nicht
verschließt euch nicht
davor merkt man eigentlich dass es schon
22 Uhr ist ich glaube schon Nummer 5 der
Dinge die ich bereue in 2023 und der
Punkt ist ein bisschen unangenehm ich
will nicht dass ihr es in falschen Hals
kriegt weil ich und andererseits muss
ich mich da auch nicht so rechtfertigen
aber ich habe mir schon vorgenommen dass
ich in
2023 nicht so häufig Alkohol trinke
also und wenn wir trinken dass
ich schneller mein Limit merke also
eigentlich wollte ich halt 2023
überhaupt keinen Kater mehr haben weil
und das weiß ich ja selber ich bin eine
Person mit anxiety ich sollte eigentlich
kein Alkohol trinken deswegen versuche
ich das halt schon in Maßen zu halten
aber ich habe mir mittlerweile halt auch
Kaffee weggenommen und so und irgendwie
will ich halt noch ein paar Sachen
behalten auch wenn Alkohol jetzt nicht
der gesündeste Aspekt im Leben ist ja
irgendwie schon in mein Leben auf jeden
Fall dazu viele Leute können ja einfach
gar nicht trinken und das ist ja auch
völlig fein aber ich hätte gerne mein
Vorhaben in die Tat umgesetzt und halt
kein Kater gehabt und die Häufigkeit
also die habe ich eigentlich ganz gut
gemeistert aber ich dachte so in manchen
Phasen ja hätte man sich auch
zurückhalten können
nur was ich mir für4 20 definitiv
vornehme ist halt wirklich das mit dem
Kater sein zu lassen ich habe das mit
Timo jetzt während vlogmas so gut
hinbekommen immer mal wieder was zu
trinken aber halt so viel dass das
wirklich komplett am nächsten Tag nichts
ausmacht und man sich vielleicht ein
bisschen müde fühlt weil man bis eins
wach war aber nicht verkatert oder
irgendwie ja so zerstört vom Vorabend
ja das fei ich gar nicht mehr und ich
mag das auch überhaupt nicht wenn wir
das dann halt in di an diesem Punkt sind
ja und da beräucht es dass ich es
2000 23 nicht geschafft
habe diese Flasche das nervt mich am
meisten Nummer se regt mich auch das da
fühle ich richtig das bereuen ach da
ärgere ich mich so also wir waren ja
jetzt ja für vlogm
in der Schweiz und in Mailand und da
waren wir auch mit japoda und so also da
hatten wir auch quasi
gearbeitet ich will bei Arbeit nee
egal ja doch vlogm ist echt harte Arbeit
in meiner Planung war das so ja dann
fahren wir in die Schweiz und dann
fahren wir nach Mailand oh das wird ja
alles so toll ja es ist es ist Arbeit
auch wenn es alles nach Spaß aussieht
und so und es ja auch wirklich Spaß
macht ist es
Arbeit aber davor waren wir dieses Jahr
keinm weg und haben nichts gemacht und
das lag auf meiner Kappe weil ich halt
die ganze Zeit meinte ja hey wir haben
noch die Wohnung gekauft und es wäre
doch bescheuert jetzt in diesem Jahr ind
dem wir in die Wohnung ziehen halt noch
ein Urlaub zu machen wir müssen auf das
Geld achten und
irgendwie also mit dem Einzug klappt's
noch nicht und so das dauert alles noch
viel länger aber irgendwie bereue ich
das jetzt dass wir das so gemacht haben
weil wer weiß wie wie lange wir noch
kinderlos sind und wer weiß wie lange
wir überhaupt auf dieser Erde noch sind
und jetzt haben wir einen Urlaub im
Sommer verpasst den wir nicht gemacht
haben weil ich halt für die Wohnung
sparen wollte man doch immer eh nicht
weiß was so auf ein
zukomt und ich glaube also was was mich
glaub ich am meisten ärgert ist dass wir
halt irgendwas günstiges hätten machen
können weil wir brauchen ja kein fün
Sterne Hotel
oder sonst was wir hätten ja auch campen
gehen können aber sich irgendwas
vornehmen das ärgert mich dass wir da
nicht trotzdem was gemacht haben auch
wenn ich Geld sparen möchte diese
geldsparerei die mache ich jetzt aber
auch schon seit wir diese Wohnung
gekauft haben und ich denke mir so ja
ist schon schlau gerade wenn ich so
andere Youtuber sehe die alle pleite
gehen wo ich mir immer noch denke wie
kann man bei einem so hohen Gehalt und
das ist ja keine Lüge das ist ja wenn
man eins über influencer weiß ist dass
die damit viel Geld verdienen können und
wie kann man dann seine Finanzen nicht
im Griff haben also ich meine so ein
Tanzverbot hat ja schon gesagt der hat
halt also Tanzverbot ist auch ein
Youtuber und ein Streamer der hat ja
gesagt der hat einfach einen zu krassen
Lifestyle gelebt ich kannst mir auch
vorstellen wenn du anfängst mit Sido zu
chillen dass du anfängst plötzlich nicht
mehr in deinen Verhältnissen zu leben
und dann hat er sich ja so
magenklamotten so gut davon halt ich ja
alles nichtich ne
ich trag die Hosen die ich mir vor 8
Jahren gekauft habe und mal kaufe ich
mir eine neue wenn sie im Trend ist und
ich irgendwie im Trend sein möchte aber
ich wei ich habe das gar nicht me das
Gefühl dass ich so im Herzen noch 16 bin
und bei Rewe 400 € verdiene und so mit
meinem Geld umgehe außer bei Essen bei
Essen mache ich wirklich einen
Unterschied also ich manchmal bereue ich
weil manchmal gebe ich zu viel aus für
dann schlechtes Essen und ich probiere
halt immer gern Neues aber wenn man es
dann verkackt und das Restaurant nicht
gut ist oder das essen was man bestellt
hat boah da könnte ich mich so Tod
ärgern man muss ja nichts man muss ja
nichts krasses machen man muss ja nichts
teures machen und das vergesse ich halt
so dann in meiner Urlaubsplanung dann
denke ich so nee Urlaub ist teuer aber
Urlaub muss ja gar nicht teuer sein wir
waren ja z.B auch in der Sächsischen
Schweiz mit muss Schwester wandern
dieses Jahr also da waren wir schon aber
das zähle ich halt nicht so als Urlaub
weil wir halt nicht zusammen lange weg
waren ich glaube wir waren da einfach
nur zwei Tage und ja das ist Urlaub aber
das ist also das ist kein Urlaub für
mich ist richtig Urlaub ist so 10 Tage
abschalten irgendwo anders sein wo man
keine alltäglichen Sachen machen kann
und ja das sind eigentlich basic meine
Regeln für den Urlaub was ich jetzt erst
seit kurzem bereue
und das zählt eigentlich nicht nur für
2023 sondern auch für alle Jahre davor
dass ich nicht mehr neue Sachen gelernt
habe seit ich vor zwei Wochen Skifahren
gelernt habe hat sich für mich eine
komplett neue Welt aufgemacht und ich
habe richtig diesen aha Moment gehabt
dass man mit 30 oder mit 25 oder wie
auch immer noch neue Sachen lernen kann
und für manche von euch ist es
vielleicht selbstverständlich und das
versteht jetzt vielleicht gar nicht dass
ich diese Erkenntnis hatte aber für mich
war das einfach nicht mehr so richtig
drin dass
man was Neues lernt weil auch wenn z.B
wenn es darum geht wenn man darüber
redet nähen so ich habe z.B eine
Nähmaschine und wenn jemand hört dass
ich eine Nähmaschine habe und so ein
bisschen nähen kann dann sagen die ja
nee ich habe das in der Schule nie
gelernt und meine Mutter hat es mir auch
nicht beigebracht
anstattdessen müsste man eigentlich
sagen nee ich habe es mir noch nicht
beigebracht oder ich habe es noch nicht
gelernt aber zu erklären warum man in
der Schulzeit das nicht lernen konnte
bestärkt ja immer mehr dass die Leute
das Gefühl haben wenn ich etwas nicht
bis 18 oder bis 15 oder so gelernt habe
ja dann ist das für mich weg dann ist es
für mich vorbei natürlich kannst du
nicht mit 30 das Klavier lernen und
plötzlich in der keine Ahnung
äpfelharmonie auftreten das braucht
bestimmt mehrere Jahre Training auch
weil die Konkurrenz wahrscheinlich
extrem hoch ist und die Leute die das
halt professionell machen wollen fangen
halt schon mit sie an
aber für die nächste Weihnachtsfeier
werden deine klavierskills auf jeden
Fall ausreichen die du auch noch mit 30
lernst oder 25 oder
45 und ich glaube das ist ich glaub das
Hirn macht das richtig gerne wenn man
noch was Neues lernt ehrlich und so hat
sich das auch angefühlt und jetzt denke
ich mir halt über all die Sachen die ich
lernen könnte und es hat sich so eine
komplett neue Welt eröffnet weil ich
hatte ja so Angst vor dem Skifahren und
dachte so nee das ist nichts für mich
und ich bin Schisser ich mag keine
Geschwindigkeit und schon gar nicht auf
irgendwelchen Holzbrettern D Berg
runterfahren also wer bin ich denn
bitte und dann gab es diesen Moment und
es hat mir Spaß gemacht und so Spaß wie
ich das echt nicht hätte für möglich
gehalten mein Gott das war fantastisch
und dann denke ich jetzt so Gott könnte
ich jetzt auch Klavier lernen ich mag
total Klaviermusik ich bin darauf gehe
ich richtig ab also ich bin ja nicht so
der musikalischste Typ aber bei
Klaviermusik da verdrücke ich immer ein
Tränchen und wenn ich da selber Klavier
lnen könnte zack oder keine Ahnung ich
gehe in der Holzwerkstatt und lerne
Tischler werden oder ich lern surfen
jetzt traue ich mir das zu jetzt traue
ich mir alles zu und ich bereue es
wirklich dass ich so lange gebraucht
habe um diese Erkenntnis zu haben und
mal aus meinem aus meinem Teufelskreis
des sich nichts Zutrauens und nichts
Neues Lernens ausgebrochen bin trotzdem
bin ich auch froh dass ich das mit 30
und nicht mit 60 erkannt habe weil ich
glaube viele Leute haben solche
Erkenntnisse auch sehr
spät aber ich glaube es ist liegt auch
immer so ein bisschen daran wie man es
also ich glaube man das liegt halt an
einem selber dass man daraus rausbricht
ich glaube wie die Eltern einem das
Vorleben so macht man es weiter und
meine Eltern haben mir definitiv
vorgelebt dass man keine Hobbys hat
vielleicht so eine Sache für die die man
ganz gerne mag aber sie muss auch
irgendwo von Nutzen sein und sie darf
nicht einfach nur für Spaß sein und ich
habe das dann einfach so übernommen und
wenn man natürlich Eltern hat die viele
Hobbys haben und die das dann auch wen
Kindern weitergeben die wachsen einfach
damit auf dass man neue Sachen
ausprobiert und guckt was einem Spaß
macht und so just for fun Dinge halt tut
Nummer acht ich bereue es nicht mehr
gelesen zu
haben ich glaub ist auch so ein
absoluter Standardspruch ne gerade so zu
Silvester rum ich werde mehr lesen ja
kommt euch das bekannt vor ich lese ein
Buch pro
Monat ärgert mich jedes Mal wenn ich
dann ein Buch gelesen habe dass ich
nicht mehr lese erstens lesen ist cool
da könnt ihr mir noch erzählen was ihr
wollt wenn ihr jemanden seht der ein
Buch in der Hand hat in der Bahn z.B
statt sein Handy man findet die Person
cooler es ist einfach so oder du datest
jemanden und dann gehst du zu der Person
nach Hause und dann hat die da total
viele Bücher und hat diese Bücher auch
alle gelesen
beeindruckend fastisch du denkst gleich
viel mehr von dieser Person als
vorher und jedes Mal wenn ich lese
liliebe ich es ich denke mir wie krass
es ist dass du in einem Buch eine ganze
Welt erschaffen kannst und du brauchst
kein CGI wie im Film du brauchst da
keine departments du brauchst kein
Regisseur der das irgendwie aufffhängt
Schauspieler die das dingst nein du
brauchst einfach nur deine Worte und du
kannst mit diesen Worten erschaffen was
du willst weil unsere Fantasie alles
möglich machen kann der Film läuft
unserem Kopf ab und ich liebe es wenn
Bücher so gut geschrieben sind dass wenn
Charaktere oder Orte beschrieben sind
dass man einfach gleich komplette
Vorstellung von hat dann sollte man sich
nicht natürlich nicht die Verfilmung
anschauen um sich die Vorstellung nicht
kaputt machen zu lassen aber ja das ist
auf jeden Fall was was ich mehr machen
möchte ich habe dieses
Jahr was man von hier aus sehen kann
gelesen ist auch ein sehr bekanntes Buch
ich weiß nicht ob ihr das das jemand von
euch kennt und ich bin gerade dabei so
ein Piratenbuch zu lesen was in meinem
Buch Adventskalender drin war die
Piraten Alf alsahari alsfari vielleicht
kennt es jemand falls ihr es kennt könnt
ihr mir schon mal sagen ob ihr es gut
fandet weil dieses Buch ist sehr dick
und ich bin jetzt gerade mit Kapitel 1
fertig und ich hoffe dass ich meine Zeit
nicht verschwende weil in diesem
Adventskalender Buch Adventskalender war
auch ein anderes Buch drin das habe ich
auch fangen und da habe ich aber nach
ich glaube 50 Seiten gesagt gut ich gebe
auf also ich wollte dem Buch eine Chance
geben aber irgendwie mit jeder Seite WD
es schlimmer und ich dachte nein aber
dann war ich schon so 30 Seiten drin und
dachte mir komm sieieh durch aber nee
ich werde nicht stundenlang ein Buch
lesen wo ich schon auf den ersten 50
Seiten einschlafen könnte bzw nicht mal
Einschlafen aber es gibt Bücher die
liest und du merkst so ne diese Person
will nicht mich damit ansprechen ich bin
hier nicht bin hier nicht die Zielgruppe
ah ja doch und dann habe ich noch so ein
ja ich habe noch ein Buch gelesen wo ich
nicht die Zielgruppe war irgend so eine
Academy in Schottland ich weiß nicht wie
ich auf dieses Buch gekommen bin aber
ich hatte das dann plötzlich mir
gekauft und dann habe ich es
gelesen und das war ganz okay aber das
war dann über so highscho Mädchen oder
über ein so ein Highschool Mädchen und
irgendwie hatte dieses highscho Mädchen
auch immer so bisschen pigme Vibes und
also ganz ehrlich bis zu diesem Buch
wusste ich nicht so richtig was die pymi
Vibes sind aber da hatte ich Pym
Vibes ja nee das Buch hatte übelste
pckny Weib wenn ich so drüber nachdenke
denn sie war nicht wie die anderen
Mädels sie liebte das
Joggen sie war halt ein bisschen
alternativer was soll sie machen ich
habe dieses
Jahr wieder mal zu viel darauf geachtet
was andere Leute über mich denken es ist
eine Berufskrankheit das muss ich dazu
sagen da könnt ihr vielleicht einige
Sachen nicht
nachvollziehen bzw Gefühlslagen nicht
nachvollziehen
aber ich sag mir das immer wieder und
knossi ist auf keinen Fall ein Vorbild
in irgendeiner Weise er ist mir zwar
sympathisch geworden durch seven versus
wild das gebe ich zu er ist jetzt aber
von seiner Vergangenheit auch mit diesem
ganzen Casino Streams und sowas ist kein
Vorbild aber in einer Sache ist er mein
größtes Vorbild und das ist seine
Selbstsicherheit und dass er einfach
Sachen macht weil ganz ehrlich man kann
sich über ihn aufregen oder ihn lieben
aber wenigstens hat man Emotionen ihm
gegenüber wisst ihr wenn die Leute ihn
lieben dann ja auch aus irgendeinem
Grund wenn die Leute was gegen ihm haben
dann ja auch aus einem Grund und nur
weil eine Person halt Fehler macht und
nicht immer super korrekt ist vielleicht
oder auch in der Vergangenheit ich will
ihm jetzt gar nichts ich glaube jetzt
ich weiß nicht was er jetzt sonst so
macht außer se ver wild aber das heißt
ja nicht dass diese Person gleich
irgendwie raus sein sollte oder
gecancelt werden sollte oder nie wieder
eine Chance hat sein Ding zu machen
und ich weiß nicht ob es die Angst vor
der cancelculture ist oder einfach weil
ich jedem gefallen möchte und nicht
damit klar kommmen würde wenn ich auch
mal so ein paar Hater
hätte aber ich wäre gerne ein bisschen
freier in dem
wie ich mich gebe bzw was ich dann auch
mal ausprobieren möchte weil dann z.B
auch so ein Monte Event ich weiß Monte
ist halt sehr kritisiert und deswegen
habe ich dann auch teilweise gedacht ja
nee dann also weißt du ich ich bemühe
mich da gar nicht hin weil Monte ist ja
nicht so ja juckt doch nicht dann gehe
ich da halt hin dann ist halt Monte
gerade nicht irgendwie everybody Darling
aber wenn ich da hingehen will dann will
ich da halt hingehen und ich würde so
gerne in
2024 viel mehr ein einfach meine Meinung
durchziehen
nicht sich schließen vor anderen
Meinungen und irgendwie total engstirnig
bleiben sagen der ist mir egal ich sehe
das halt so offen sollte man immer
bleiben aber auch mal so ein bisschen
einfach sein eigenen Charakter
durchscheinen lassen und ich glaube ich
tue das schon oft aber manchmal habe ich
auch das Gefühl so ein bisschen mehr
würde gehen und ein bisschen weniger
darüber nachdenken was jetzt das absolut
perfekt korrekte ist ich will schon
moralisches Vorbild sein aber ich
vermisse manchmal bei mir selber dann so
eine Ecke und so eine Kante das macht ja
meistens dann auch Leute interessant
solange man nicht irgendwelche
moralischen Grenzen wirklich
überschreitet das ist auch noch mal
wichtig zu sagen aber so ein bisschen
weil mit meinen Freunden und so da rede
ich manchmal ein bisschen taffer da sage
ich manchmal auch also wie sage ich das
jetzt ohne dass ihr denkt dass ich
irgendwie da sage ich manchmal Sachen
die ich wirklich denke aber nichts
ansatzweise rechtes also in diese
Richtung geht das auch nicht und auch
nichts menschenverachtnes aber halt in
was ja was Männer z.B angeht oder dann
ne meine Meinung zu irgendwas ja ich
würde es halt gerne einfach bisschen
bisschen offener teilen meine Gedanken
und Gefühle und z.bpiel hatte ich das
dieses Jahr extrem gemerkt und ich
glaube das hat mich dann auch mega weil
ich das auch bei den bei manchen
Kommentaren gelesen habe dass ich in den
adventskalenderv Videos teilweise nicht
hart genug war und das kommt
daher dass ich bei diesem ess
Adventskalender von vor z Jahren oder
letztes Jahr da habe ich halt meine
Meinung gesagt wie ich das halt sehe und
da gab es halt so
viel negatives Feedback dass zu meinen
Aussagen die ich ja so empfinde und so
halt gesagt habe dass ich nicht darüber
stehen konnte und einfach sagen konnte
ja gut dann sind wir halt verschiedener
Meinung Zuschauer xy und ich nee dann
ist es gleich so oh nee da habe ich mich
falsch geäußert weil für viele Menschen
ist das ja nicht so wie ich das gesagt
habe und das ist ja dann jetzt falsch
ich muss sowas halt auch mal aushalten
können und ich bin mir sicher dass nicht
gleich
alle die restlichen Videos für immer
skippen werden und nie wieder was von
mir anschauen werden nur weil ich einmal
nicht oder weil wir einmal nicht
derselben Meinung waren
ja da versuche ich mal so ein
bisschen Arsch in der Hose zu kriegen ne
wir machen jetzt noch Nummer 10 dann
wasche ich meine Haare aus und zeige
euch vielleicht noch das Ergebnis ich
bereue es in diesem Jahr und Nummer 10
ist so klein im Vergleich zu allen
anderen ich bereue es so sehr keine
Weihnachtskarten verschickt zu haben
hear me out ich verschicke seit Jahren
Weihnachtskarten und zwar nicht normale
die ich irgendwo gekauft habe nein ich
drucke selber Designs die ich gemacht
habe witzige Designs Designs mit Timo
zusammen ich habe mich letztes Jahr
glaube ich war das oder vorletztes Jahr
zeichnen lassen von einer Illustratorin
oder Timo und mich so am Weihnachtsbaum
das war auch so eine mega coole Karte
und ich habe diese Tradition geliebt und
das witzigste war egal zu wem wir nach
Hause gekommen sind irgendwo haben wir
unsere Weihnachtskarten an irgendeiner
Pinnwand gesehen ob es jetzt bei Kelly
war oder bei Timos Eltern bei meiner
Schwester jeder hatte diese
Weihnachtskarten aufgehangen und
aufbewahrt weil die einfach sehr unique
waren und ich ärgere mich und bereue es
halt extrem dieses Jahr nicht eine
verschickt zu haben auch wenn es nur
eine Weihnachtskarte
ist ich finde für solche Dinge muss Zeit
bleiben man lebt in dieser schnellbigen
Welt und es geht auch gerade ja bei mir
viel um Klicks und Likes
und neue Ideen und hier bist du im Trend
und und bist du gerade noch cool und ne
hast du irgendwie bist du eingeladen auf
den Events und bist du überall
und hast du Wachstum wech dein Kanal
wech dein Instagram account we dein we
dein tiktok Account
was kannst du machen damit der
Algorithmus so in dieser Welt und da
muss einfach Zeit bleiben für Dinge wie
eine Tradition eine Weihnachtskarte
gemacht zu haben und egal wie schön
vlogm dieses Jahr war und wie cool ich
es finde dass wir es durchziehen und
wahrscheinlich auch wirklich bis zum 24
schaffen ich hätte mir die Zeit nehmen
sollen diese Weihnachtskarte zu
gestalten weil mir das einfach wichtig
war und es nicht irgendwelchen Erfolg
dadurch gibt es gibt kein ich hätte das
auch nicht mal geteilt so wirklich ich
glaube ich habe das die letzten Jahre
jaimmer so nebenbei irgendwie gezeigt
also da ging es ja nie um
Content da ging es einfach nur um was
mir wichtig ist und das habe ich
verraten und da wird aus einer klein
Sache wie eine Weihnachtskarte wird da
was ganz Großes ganz dieep
ja aber was soll man machen Fehler sind
da um sie
zu tun
und gleich jetzt seht ihr das Ergebnis
und das ist das nachher Timo sagt es
sieht jetzt ordentlicher aus und ich
finde auch mir steht das Schwarz
irgendwie noch ein Ticken besser auch
wenn braun schön ist und es jetzt
wahrscheinlich nicht für euch so ein
Riesenunterschied ist finde ich schon
das gefällt mir schön für die holidays
mache ich jetzt ein bisschen auf
schnewitchen und vergesst auf jeden Fall
nicht das Gewinnspiel hier habe ich noch
mal die Tickets ich muss aber
das Verdecken wo ihr hier luschern
könntet also diese tickets könnt ihr
jetzt auf Instagram gewinnen macht
schnell mit denn das Gewinnspiel ist nur
24 Stunden da weil ich halt die Tickets
schnell noch verchicken
möchte also das Deichen Festival vom 18
bis zum 21 Juli 2024 vielleicht sehen
wir uns ja dort und ich gehe jetzt Yoga
machen das seht ihr dann morgen